the best Jackass movie was number two
just because we were in our hey day we
were so reckless everything was working
we got away with everything and uh
Jackass 3D was way more commercially
successful but I think without the
phantom camera the super slow motion the
3D without all of that I think you're on
the super radical like you just like the
ready to die right yeah Jackass 2 is
ready to die everyone is ready to die
willing to die it's the gnarliest one
right right right very right uh I love
3D I think 3D they all have including
what we just shot is the the spirit of
this camaraderie and the love of this
group maybe my feeling about Jackass 3D
is just that because I was newly sober I
was just like uncomfortable in my skin I
hadn't found my voice I was just like
this sort of afraid emotional nerve then
on this one that's not the case